il était une fois toutes les histoires
commence comme ça ok ok il pleut sur la
thèse comme ils pleurent dans mon coeur
ma vie vous prisonnière d'un
environnement où il fallait avoir enfin
être qu'est ce qu'on a fait nous
embarquer pour y aller je parle comme je
sache lâche du 10e au toit démenti faire
fort comme tangents tout plaire à tout
le monde
ma bibliothèque mes livres sont mais
seul bling les jce va bientôt terminer
ses études secondaires et ses notes sont
excellents nous nous sommes permis de
proposer son dossier pour hypokhâgne et
il a été accepté
en fait c'est quoi et pour compliquer
ses hippo cannes
pour moi ça va les hippocampes c'est
possible comme
assad il parle à goku de l'hérault au
plomb - vendegies sur ton pour la cua
août lhc grosse peine durera pas toute
ne fera rien tant de joueurs journée ça
la solidarité cousin
j'ai choisi un prénom opthalmologiques
n'était un concert de la laiterie le
mois dernier c'était super tout le monde
au pour avoir quoi ça peut l'être
pourquoi bien sûr
je suis né du tribunal créé par dj pis
je vais prendre et puis j'ai appelé pour
l'épreuve
rappelle-toi lycée a fait un choix
donc pas se sentir étranger dans le pays
nos pays c'est la france